do you think that we are in a climate
crisis
globally right now yes
i believe that we are i don't know
why we are not making this our number
one priority
and i know covet is our priority and
right behind it
should be the destruction
of this planet our water our air
and knowing that changes are coming and
we still won't get prepared
the conversation has to be had it has to
be loud
and it has to be all of us how
shocked and disappointed are you at the
kind of status of america when it comes
to tackling climate change
on the global stage i'm really
frustrated and you know i always i
really try to
listen understand respect
hear both sides certainly the people
i've been doing this i started at 31
i'm 60. nothing's changed
one key issue appears to be
environmental racism
and we have seen that play out in places
like detroit
in michigan where people are dealing
with really grave levels of toxicity
in the air do you think that america is
confronting
environmental racism enough no
and i don't think we have been and i've
been out here for 20 years and they're
at a disadvantage and they get taken
advantage of it's wrong at every ever
i'm see i'm not going to drop an f-bomb
and i almost did it's wrong
at every level and it sickens me
they're just being assaulted assaulted
by everything that you could possibly
think of
food air water land and the state's a
real
in a real quagmire you've got chromium-6
contamination you got refineries you've
got
air pollution after everything that
y'all just went through up there with
flint michigan
and antiquated infrastructures
wow and you're doing what over there
decades ago i did hinckley and i'm still
sitting here having this conversation
with you today it's frustrating it's
disappointing it makes me angry
and i don't understand whoever those
powers to be why it is
you can't hear the people
who are down on the ground drinking the
water
eating the food living in these
conditions
frightened suffering and nothing
has gotten done we don't always see the
big picture right
so we think what's happening in mission
may just be happening in michigan
but it also happened in hinkley but i'm
here to tell you it's happening in maine
and it's happening in oklahoma
how comforting to you that america is
going to be able to catch up
quickly enough because it seems to be a
long way behind on this
for as daunting as everything sees i see
a watershed moment i see the great reset
i see the great reboot and
it's here and the conversation is had
the generations are engaged and we're
going to march forward
and change tell me erin do you think joe
biden's climate proposals are ambitious
enough
i think we're going to go there i'm
hopeful that we're going to go there